okay yeah
kung fu is absolutely crazy about
strawberry jam at only four months old
he's the youngest resident in the animal
sanctuary like these other young bears
kung fu was seized from illegal animal
traders his handler Fatone yang from
free the Bears has been fattening him up
since he arrived
normally young Bears spend the first
three years of their lives with their
mothers but they're usually killed and
the Cubs are kept under awful conditions
kung Fu's brother died in captivity this
fully grown Asian black bear also called
a moon bear stands nearly two meters
high and weighs about 150 kilograms in
tat kuang SI sanctuary in northern laos
the animals live in the most natural
conditions possible hardly any of the
visitors can imagine the ordeal these
poor animals have been through in the
illegal farms activist Luke Nicholson
explains to the visitors that bear bile
is used in traditional Chinese medicine
in a pebble farm there's a house in tiny
cages no bigger than the Bears
themselves and they can live up 20 years
inside those pages where bear bile is
extracted through surgical means from
the bay using a syringe these pictures
show a bear bile farm near the Lao Shan
capital vientiane there are an estimated
15 illegal operations like this in Laos
it's actually illegal in Laos to treat
animals like this but there's hardly any
enforcement 38 Asian moon bears now live
here cageless and carefree but their
enclosure was only designed to house ten
animals releasing these gentle giants
back into the wild would be too
dangerous
the Bears that have been hand raised it
have imprinted on humans if we were to
release them back to the wild that go
directly to a village looking for food
and that's where we get human bear
conflict and that's when people in bears
die free the Bears is building a much
larger refuge about an hour's drive from
the historic city of Luang Prabang with
room for about 150 bears the government
and Laos is finally making an effort to
close down the cruel and illegal bear
bile farms the rescued animals will
finally get a new home nestled in this
natural setting